light yourself on fire Jesus is back
that's Jesus talking Jesus just got a
blue checkmark how did he get verified
he was 12 followers FX's latest sci-fi
miniseries from the writer director of X
Mackin eyes a mind-bending thriller that
asks the question can Nick Offerman play
a serious role literally listening to
turkey calls in this video we're gonna
take a deep dive into the ending and
explain some of its most unanswered
questions so login to the system because
here we go the very first shot of the
final episode is of the crashed capsule
we aren't sure what's really happened
yet as this particular scene occurs near
the end of the episode in essence we're
seeing a glimpse of the future just like
Forrest and Kay to use the dev's machine
to see the future this technique of
showing images of future events at the
start of the episodes occurs several
times throughout the series like in
Episode two where it briefly shows us
the fight between Anton and Kenton that
hasn't yet happened set against the
intro we have Stewart reciting William
Butler Yeats his poem the second coming
which uses Christian imagery regarding
the apocalypse and second coming to
describe the atmosphere of post-war
Europe in devs however it describes the
atmosphere of Devas destruction and the
death of its creator but as we'll find
out later devs looks as though it's
seemingly destroyed but with it comes
resurrection if you're watching the last
episode is second time you'll notice
this introductory shot of Forrest here
is him post-death being within the
system and the image of his daughter
running through the field is the one we
later see her in at the end of the
episode rewinding 30 minutes Lily
arrives at devs to confront Forrest in
episode 7 we learned that Forrest gave
Lily permission to bypass security and
access the hub that's because he's seen
the future and knows what's going to
happen even if that future shows his own
death forced is powerless to stop it
that's because he's a firm believer in
determinism in philosophy determinism is
the idea that all events including moral
choices are completely determined by
previously existing causes nothing ever
happens without a reason everything was
determined by some
in Prior in other words we have no free
will that's why when forest confronts
Sergei about stealing his source code he
tells him he's not mad you made known
decision to betray me you could only
have done what you did force wants to
believe so badly in determinism because
it would absolve him of the guilt he
holds for the deaths of his wife and
child he kept his wife distracted on the
phone while she was driving which
resulted in her deadly car crash if
there is no such thing as free will then
he can't be to blame for their deaths
I think Deb's is how you've put yourself
on trial it's judge and jury if it works
determinism precludes free will and
you're absolved you did no wrong
but if it doesn't work
you had choices enter guilty this is why
in Episode four forest fires linden
linden applied a code that used american
physicist hugh Everett's many-worlds
theory in order to get a crystal-clear
audio recording of Jesus Christ but the
Everett theory which basically states
that there are infinite worlds where
people make infinite choices flies in
the face of determinism it means the
universe is constantly splitting like
the trunk and branches and twigs of an
infinitely large tree and on that tree
all possible worlds will exist in
essence the application of Linden's code
proves that Free Will exists this force
was responsible for the death of his
wife and daughter knowing this it
becomes clear as to why forest fired
linden when in any other world linden
would have been given the Nobel Prize
as a side note the actor who plays
London is female even though the
character is referred to using male
pronouns it just so happens Alex Garland
the writer director had a certain look
in mind for this character and woman
just happened to fit the bill
moving along force tries to make sense
of this discovery by stating that yes
they heard Jesus but it wasn't there
Jesus by taking all this data from
supposedly many universes it does not
recreate the exact Jesus that was the
one that lived in their history if it's
not our Jesus it's not my Maya Lily
joins Forest in the theater room with
the feeling of helplessness she feels
that she's not in control of her own
life I don't know what I am anymore
something that makes no decisions has no
choices
forced understands because the feeling
of participating in life is just an
illusion life is something we merely
watch unfold
he says determinism may be strange but
it's also beautiful forced explains that
once you understand the state of one
particle you can understand the state of
the ones around it until eventually you
know everything throughout the season
we've seen this experiment of a mouse
surrounded by different objects in
episode 5 we see the first time the devs
employees conduct this experiment to see
if they can simulate what happened to
the mouse in the past by using these
objects examining their particles in
relation to one another they can get an
image of the mouse back in time force
tells Olli that he knows she's holding
onto Kenton's gun something he could
only know if he had looked into the
future if this machine really has the
power to do that then Lily wants to see
what's in store in the simulation we see
Lily take Forrest at gunpoint toward the
capsule her plan is to take him to the
statue of a maiya and kill him the same
place where Serkis burnt body was left
Lily tells them that these tech leaders
believe their messiahs but forest fires
back you know what happens to the sires
dog
they get resurrected and that's exactly
what will later happen to both Lilly and
Forrest in fact they're the only two
characters who get these halos around
them similar to the Messiah Jesus Christ
Lilly ends up shooting Forrest causing
the capsule to crash in Lilly to
ultimately die at least that's what this
simulation says will happen back in real
time forced explains that devs isn't the
actual name for the project the V in
devs is actually Latin which the Romans
pronounced as the letter you making devs
actually Deus the Latin word for God
although it was meant as a joke it
really implies that Forrest sees himself
as a god Lilly takes Forrest out at
gunpoint just like this simulation
predicted she would however instead of
shooting for she throws the gun away
before the doors to the capsule close
she has proven the simulation wrong and
that she does have free will you know
the thing about Messiah is Dillian
or false prophets Stuart however has
different plans he disables the
electromagnetic field holding up the
capsule and it smashes to the ground
killing lily and Forrest he did it
because his character believes such a
machine shouldn't exist and that it
needed to be stopped a change of
character from the Stuart we saw earlier
in the series this change began with the
firing of linden and I'm sure when
linden sought him out and said this it
helped to he's obsessive he kills people
he's trying to resurrect his daughter do
you really want something as powerful as
doves in the hands of someone crazy
Stuart begins to see forest and the devs
project in a different light even sing
in episode 7 such big decisions being
made about our future by people who know
so little about our past when Katie
asked him why he did it he makes a joke
saying not to blame him it was
predetermined now there is a theory that
Lily's choice of throwing the gun
doesn't matter at all check out these
two shots of Stuart and the screen to
his left one of them is from the
simulation and the other is of reality
yet the screen is the same having been
programmed by Stuart to disable the
electromagnetic system on both this
theory states that it doesn't matter
whether or not Lili throws the gun out
or not Stuart will still disable the
system killing forest and Lily this
theory would also mean that the world is
still deterministic but I want to hear
your comments below on what you think
force wakes up in the theatre room
although this time he is the one being
projected katy has uploaded all his
memories data everything leading up to
his death into Deb's the reason Katie
and forest couldn't see beyond the date
of Lily's death was because she made a
choice force calls it the original sin
disobedience just like Adam and Eve ate
from the forbidden fruit going against
the laws of God so too did Lily make a
choice that deviated from his plan Katy
informs Forrest that the system is now
all-knowing but only when using Linden's
principle she needs to know if forest
understands this it would mean that he
was wrong that there is no such thing as
determinism that he did have some
responsibility for the death of his
family but it also means there is hope
for resurrection in a world where he can
live the rest of his days within one of
these worlds
Lily however wakes up next to
on the same day as Episode one
everything has been reset to this day
but she has the knowledge of everything
that happened up to her death she knows
about Serge's secret Sudoku app for
example you may even have caught a
glance at linden and Stuart who were
happily having a conversation on campus
she goes in search of forest ironically
enough through a forest and sees him
reunited with his wife and daughter in
this world they did not die forest tells
her that she has her life back that the
two of them have been resurrected we are
now living in many worlds in this world
the two of us get to live in paradise
with the ones we love Lily isn't sure
what to do with her life now and Forest
says she can follow her own path
something he never would have said at
the beginning of the series in the real
world however Lily and forest are dead
as chief operating officer of devs Katie
has taken control and has done something
forced never would have done let the
senator in on what devs really is if you
remember from episode 3 the senator
visited forest in an attempt to learn
more about devs trying to recruit the
program so that it can be used by the
NSA Forest whoever couldn't care less
about using devs to help others not for
patriotic reasons or as he tells Kenton
to combat climate change forest cares
about one thing only being with his
family and that's exactly why Katie goes
to the senator although it's never fully
explained Katie needs the senator in
order to keep devs running this could
mean she needs help financially or
legally because if devs is disabled
she'll lose the person she loves forests
just like forests would do anything to
protect the project that includes murder
so too does Katie do what she needs to
do in order to keep forests alive
forests the observer has now become the
observe perhaps Katie may one day have
aspirations of also being reunited with
him the final scene however is between
Lily and Jamie with her restart Lily is
able to forge her own path and make her
own decisions this means she can be with
the one she cares about most with their
knowledge of Sergey being a spy and the
links to which Jamie went to protect her
she has made the decision to patch
things up with him something that didn't
go over too well when she tried to use
him in Episode one to crack her missing
boyfriends phone
we'll ditch Sergey as she says to Jamie
at the end of episode 6 I didn't know
him I know you so stay in my bed at its
core devs isn't a story about solving a
murder it's the story of what it means
to be human
are we slaves to a deterministic world
where everything is predetermined by
cause and effect or do we have free will
is there one world where everything
plots a course on a singular tramline or
are there multiple worlds like a tree
branching out infinitely into the
universe in the end it's up for you to
decide
thanks for watching everyone please be
sure to LIKE and subscribe and leave
your thoughts and theories in the
comments below you can also follow me on
twitter at the story whitey until next
time remember daddy loves you very much